Hi Jessie how are you
Hi Steve
Today, I have a chance and talk with
Jessie has a channel, its name is
"Chinese with Jessie"
Jessie has helped many people to
learn Chinese
Chinese is a very important language
Now, I have a few questions for
Jessie
Jessie, could you introduce your
channel to us?
Which country person watches your
channel are from
How are you helping them?
Could tell us how many years
you have done?
Ok, my channel's name is
"Chinese with Jessie"
It was founded in May 2020
I only taught Chinese at first
For example
How do you say?
How do you reply to thank you? "
Like as teach and study
And then,
I slowly incorporated some of
the popular cultures in the West
and teaching Chinese
through a cultural export method
My target audience is from
the US, UK, Canada, etc.
These most audiences are from English
Of course, we all know,
the Chinese culture is very long
it means the history is very long
And in our world,
people with Chinese-speaking
probably about 20% of
the world's population
But you think,
what is the biggest attraction of
learning Chinese right now?
Or what is the biggest reason/purpose
when I first start teaching students,
I usually ask this question
Why do they want to learn Chinese
because he wants the goal of
achievement is different
Then, the content and process of our
teaching maybe are also different.
In general, my students would
give me several answers.
One is that he is going to
come to China for study
Another is he want to do business
in China
There are a lot of students like this
They have many business partners
who are Chinese
Or they want to expand their business
into China
The purpose of this kind of person
is for business，for learning
And another kind of students,
his love or companion is Chinese
So he wants to learn Chinese
some more student,
Because he just like Chinese culture
and history
Because as you just said
China has a history of above
5,000 years
This is a very long history
So many people have been attracted
by these factors.
Including maybe some of the
Chinese culture familiar in the West
such as Chinese martial arts,
and Chinese food are very famous
Except for the factor interested in
Chinese culture,
mostly knows, China's economic
development is also very fast
Therefore economic development will
also have a very positive impact
on the world economy.
So I think maybe have more people
will think about these two
long-term directions
so they are going to learn Chinese
In general, how old are the students
who study with you
Ah...
the average age difference is huge
Young students may be in high school
or younger
The older students...
I have taught a student
His age should be more than 50 years
He wants to learn Chinese
from beginning
There are students of all ages.
Whether in my private lessons
or the person watching my channel
their age is a huge difference.
I think it's also a good thing
Whether young or people who
have lived a long time in the West
They are all interested in Chinese no
I'm very happy
If a person learns Chinese from
the beginning level,
how many years does he need to spend?
And then, he can understand better
with Chinese films
or he is able to talk with Chinese
How many years will he need to take
to touch the fluency level?
This is a question that many people
ask too.
But it really is according to
the personal,
The difference between each student
can be very large
I have many friends
who have been in China for 2-3 years
but they can't speak a sentence
in Chinese
Some people have come seven or eight
he still can't speak Chinese fluently
because they didn't feel the need
to learn Chinese
Or they are not interested
in Chinese
So, even if you are in China
Everyone speaks Chinese, but you stil
It's like he's blocking himself
He seems to block all the information
as something incomprehensible
So it depends on your personal intere
how much time you plan to spend
on this thing
Of course, also, whether you have
the right way to learn
I feel learning fast
if you have the right way
Maybe in less than two years,
or about a year,
he can start to communicate
with the Chinese
Of course, if you don't spend a lot
of time to learning Chinese
but you want to achieve the fluent
level
I think this is contradictory
maybe it is difficult
Of course, you live in China,
that's fine
you will progress faster
If you live in the UK or US
then it's not that easy
So the problem isn't about age
The problem is that you are willing
to focus on your studies,
and you are willing to learn
It's more important that your
attitude and spending  time than age,
right?
Yep
And the question of where you live
Actually, like me
many people ask me if I have
studying or living in a Western count
I actually don't have
I was born and grew up in China
but I can also speak English
achieve speaking a fluency level
You can see a lot of people in China
His Chinese may not be good too.
So I think, actually,
the environment is you can create you
If I learn Chinese,
then I have to go to China
I agree
If I learn English,
then I must go to the UK and US,
and I can learn well.
Uncertain! Some people go
and he can't learn well
Some people do not go but learn well
Like just we said, your enthusiasm
your method
your attitude
These factors will be more important
than your geographic location
Um, I agree,
I study Mandarin in Hong Kong
That was in 1968. Almost no one
spoke Mandarin in Hong Kong in 1968
Except for my teachers
that time
Hong Kong is totally a Cantonese
environment
Not be a Mandarin environment
But I achieve my current
within about one year
At that time,
I was very focused on my studies,
Spending five or six months in each
year. Either listen, read, or write
or talk with teachers
And I lived in Japan for 9 years
Many foreigners have lived in Japan
for a long time
They can't speak Japanese
So it's all up to you,
I absolutely agree
But
Learning Chinese has a problem
about Chinese characters
it is a big difficulty
emm... Is it easier for the Japanese
learn Chinese?
than westerners
because they already have Chinese cha
Yes! A large part of their language i
in Chinese characters.
This is mutual influence
I think whether Chinese learn Japanes
or Japanese learning Chinese
may already have an advantage over pe
Because we already know each other
some parts of the language
I think we maybe  know almost half
the word
The pronunciation is although
different
but when I see the character
then I know its means
I have gone ahead of the others.
I traveled to Japan before
At the time, I just only speak
1-2 sentences  of Japanese
But I'm walking the streets of Japan
I can understand the road signs
and I can understand the menu of
the restaurant
But I speak, they don't understand
I think this is an interesting thing
We all know what this thing is
But he didn't understand what I said
I need a translator to tell him what
want to say
However, I think learning the languag
will definitely be easier than people
in others
Last question
For example, when I was learning
Persian
My online teacher, Tuter
He helped me find a lot of interestin
podcast material
and the history of Iran
there are also TV shows
there are many things
we can all use it to learn the langua
I know people who learn English
they have some study materials
in the US
Such as "Friends", "tears" or other l
Is there any such learning material i
Help them learn
After Chinese has reached a certain
level
they need to through real Tv shows
to improve the level of Chinese
Can you introduce?
do you have this kind of material
on your channel?
Learning Chinese materials on the web
I think if you want to learn from the
TV show
I think movies and TV shows are good
learning materials
But if it's a variety show
it might be more difficult
because they speak very fast
subtitles are very fast too
In general,  TV shows and movies
if you find the right one
Some speak more slowly
And especially TV shows
there may be many episodes
You can follow the plot
My spoken English  is learned through
watching English movies and TV shows.
Because I didn't go to an internation
I have never learned from any
English teacher
I learn in this way myself
I think it makes you more interested
and motivated to learn
learn more actively
Because I want to watch TV shows
So I will actively learn
I don't study because I have to study
English today
so I'm looking for some materials
to learn
This feeling is different
In my channel, I will talk about some
Chinese movies
Recently, I made a video
a movie about China
It was also famous in
the United States at that time,
called "Crouching Tiger, Hidden Drago
Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon
Yeah, this movie
Oh~~, yeah
I will also talk about some of these
Chinese films.
You can also watch my channel
If there are text or subtitles
we can import to link
Then I can learn
Because if I don't have text?
just listening
not easy
It's not easy to remember those new w
But if the voice matches the text
I think it very helpful
All right! Now more and more study
materials are available
to help people learn languages
including Chinese
I hope
more and more people
to join us is to learn languages ​​
all over the world
And I think like you using the
internet to teach language
such as the language teachers will be
more and more.
Much
this method will become more
mainstream than compared
with traditional schools,
I think in a few years
According to current trends
All right!  Thank you!
Thanks, Steve!
We will put the linke of your channel
in my description
So I hope our audience to
join your channel
That is good! Thanks,  Steve!
Thanks Jessie!
Bye bye